Speaker 1: I want to play a couple of clips
for you of a man appearing thrilled that Nancy
Pelosi has covered.
This is this is really disgusting stuff.
A back during the late period, the late era,
the late stages of the Trump administration,
you had people like Don, Junior and others
saying Democrats are taking pleasure in people
getting COVID and dying of COVID.
And of course, it wasn't true.
There were it just wasn't true, it wasn't
happening.
It wasn't happening.
But I'm going to play a clip for you now of
Trump speaking somewhere.
Who even knows where he really seems to be
taking pleasure in playing very coy with Nancy
Pelosi testing positive for COVID?
Nancy Pelosi is 82 years old.
Hopefully, she's well protected from the vaccine.
I've not seen an update as to how she's doing
over the last 48 hours, but hopefully she's
improving.
And here's Trump kind of goading the crowd
with We want her to get, well, right.
Right.
And you can tell exactly what he's doing here.
Unidentified: Nancy Pelosi is in charge of
security at the Capitol.
Lock her up,
Speaker 1: by the way.
Lock her up again, the people that say they're
for law and order say skip due process, don't
charge her.
Don't try her.
She's not even being investigated for anything.
Just lock her up.
That's not law and order, guys.
Unidentified: Lock her up.
Her off, lock her up,
Speaker 2: lock her up.
Speaker 1: OK, now we're having trouble with
the video.
Let's see if we can get the video back here.
OK.
Technical issues plaguing us today.
OK, let's get back to it here, right?
So Trump says we want her to get well, right,
everybody want her to get well.
And the crowd says, no, I wanted
Speaker 2: to get loud.
She's got the China virus.
I don't know if it's a strong case or not,
but she got it just out.
Some insiders have just had.
You know, Nancy Pelosi is in charge of Capitol
security is in my.
Speaker 1: So, so Trump really seems shaken
up there by by by Nancy Pelosi of having coronavirus.
And then here's just one other really weird
clip from this event.
Speaker 2: I think you're probably more aware
of what's the children are risking their lives
to try to learn.
Speaker 1: They released the China virus,
so after years, after years of no evidence
that China released anything and guys, if
they did, I want to know, investigate.
I've never been one of these people that says
it's racist to ask the question.
If you get the if the first cases are in country
A.
You look at countries and say, well, what
happened there, but there's no evidence that
China released anything, but it doesn't matter.
Trump keeps alluding to that.
And the word
Speaker 2: they comes from the way I held
it, that word coming from it had all sorts
of things.
The only thing that you want to mention was
the name China.
Speaker 1: OK, so continuing just everything,
everything bizarre about this event.
And you know it, we continue.
As I've said before, the level of projection
from these folks is wild.
They say, Look at this, the other side is
doing that.
They're probably doing it themselves.
Hillary with sensitive information, private
email servers, records keeping.
They're going to rob.
They're going to try to steal the election,
will they?
They tried to steal the election even though
Trump lost.
And with all we, they want people to die of
COVID.
You guys are the guys who seem to laugh whenever
a Democrat gets it, whenever a prominent Democrat
gets it.
These are these are disgusting people, and
they are everything that they accuse the left
of doing.
They actually are themselves.
It's vile to see